there's two main ingredients you just  chose mine but but that doesn't matter  this is how they sell Scientology no  there you go do you believe in aliens I  want to show you some literature about  orange juice doesn't matter  you know what you're a guy that only  sees two genders you know you see  everything too simply I like this I love  I love this that is not true because I  don't know what the [ __ ] I'm looking at  right now  [Music]  it is the day of my daughter's kissing  yeah  is not a fair argument you're making  right now what are you talking about as  you slur your dumb words  you dummy  yeah  listen  just because my eyes are closed don't  doesn't mean I'm drunk  that should be a t-shirt taste buddies  look he's slopping out of me yeah  so much today already  [Laughter]